you guys worked on what we call Bad
Santa
yeah which um as you know I saw the
original cut way back when lost my mind
lost my mind watching that first cut
um you mentioned yesterday when we were
talking and I had no idea that Mickey
Rooney Mickey Rooney auditioned for the
movie yeah he auditioned to play Marcus
the dwarf or the elf I'm sorry uh and uh
he famously there was a videotape that
Terry zweigoff has yeah we're doing
enough we're doing another project we're
going on the town with Terry we're going
to do another project with Terry uh this
amazing series that he wrote about
record collecting and uh about shellac
records and he it's amazing we're gonna
go out on the town with that now but so
but he and we're hoping we're doing we
want to talk about this because we want
Terry to dig into his closet because
there's a VHS of Mickey Rooney
auditioning as Marcus because the whole
thing is is that Mickey Rooney he'd be
doing the scenes and you know the
profanity it's like was the at the time
it was the most F words in any movie and
Mickey Rooney would be doing the scene
and he would like the time would come up
for him to say he would he would
just go and pause and then he would go
on and then another like a you
pause and he would go on and then Terry
said to him he said Mickey why aren't
you saying the dialogue he goes there's
a lady Pleasant present I don't I will
do it on the day I'll do it on the day
but for now for now because there's a
lady president because there won't be
any ladies on the set I guess yeah
because he's old Hollywood did he come
close to getting the role or no I have
no idea no I don't think he did I think
it was a bridge
my favorite thing we showed up on one of
the one of the shooting days of bad
Santa and we saw um uh uh you know
Marcus uh Tony Cox any you know he's
African-American and he had the little
white
Caucasian ear elf tips
like this is my genius moment oh and by
the way
um the uh what was he oh God I have
another one what's the other great one
the Marcus story
[Music]
um
no no no no no oh well we were when Joel
and Ethan were pitching us the idea they
go uh we're out to dinner with Joel and
Ethan and they said we have this idea
for a movie called Bad Santa he drinks
beer and stuff that was the thing with
Stitch and then and then and then we
said okay while we have this Robert
Westlake that we're obsessed with
so we're gonna we think we can turn that
batsana into like a Robert Westlake
Donald Trump Donald Wesley Donald Wesley
a movie and and so we went off and and
but then during dinner we were drinking
wine and having a good time and they
started telling stories about the little
person who was on Oh Brother Where Art
Thou and was it Oh Brother Where Art
there yeah I think yeah and he was like
a complete dick
and he was like he would talk to the
producers like why do you put me on the
25th floor I can't reach the 25th button
you know he was just like a complete
dick and we're like oh well that's going
in the movie
[Laughter]